[Musique]
la situation est désespérée
l'egypte y vont tomber dans la maladie
les shadoks pour y échapper se déguise
en passoire où on ressort de lits mais
la maladie venait à bout des ressorts
s'infiltrait dans les passoires les plus
étanches s'infiltrait dans le golfe
découvrez d'énormes réserves de shadocks
qu'elle ré précis c'est beaucoup périr
et nourrit du shadow que la maladie
redoublé de vigueur et de méchanceté si
bien qu'à la fin la planète elle-même se
mit à rétrécir d'autres pays
mais voyez comme les choses sont
drôlement c'est le ji me fous dans la
fusée voyons que la planète rapetisser
crier mais je le recul je recule et il a
versé des commandes si bien qu'ils se
mettaient à reculer pour de vrai et
l'egypte y furent sauvés mais pour les
shadoks c'était autre chose
les pauvres bêtes panis qui sautait dans
la puce et sont même contre le temps de
se changer
les shadoks bombe a sauté dans la leur
or la fusée d'euros qui était à
l'endroit ne marchait pas à l'endroit
tandis que l'accusé d'en bas qui était à
l'envers ne marchait pas à l'envers
c'est à dire que j'ai une certaine
mesure elle marche est alors une voix et
d'autres encore ce qui tombait en
descendant essayer de s'agripper à ceux
qui tombèrent en montant bien il se
hissait sur les ustensiles qui flottait
entre temps à force de manger trop de
shadocks la maladie était tombé malade
et les sa partie
rescapés et les uns ont tassé dans des
tiroirs les autres dont des casseroles
ou des passoires
c'est ainsi que commença pour eux le
long et pénible voyage qui devait en
principe les amener sur la terre
[Musique]